[Applaus]
ich nenne es mal die Meldung der Woche
Nancy fazer unsere Innenministerin ist
offensichtlich total unterfordert denn
sie stürzt sich zusätzlich als
SPD-Spitzenkandidatin in den hessischen
Wahlkampf wobei wenn ich darüber
nachdenke nur zwei Jobs sind eigentlich
auch viel zu wenig für die Frau ich gehe
fest davon aus dass sie außerdem bald
die Hertha rettet und beim esc-antritt
und warum auch nicht warum nicht
Innenministerin das kannst Du
wahrscheinlich auch halbtags machen ja
das bisschen innere Sicherheit cyberkram
und Terror Abwehr Nancy bist du dir
sicher dass das mit Hessen eine gute
Idee ist
ich nicke und rufe ganz laut ja
und ich schüttel den Kopf und Frage ganz
laut wirklich
meine alleine die Migrationsthemen über
die wir gerade völlig zu Recht reden
während schon ein Vollzeitjob wenn man
drüber nachdenkt sowohl das BAMF als
auch die Ausländerbehörden wissen vor
lauter Arbeit nicht mehr was sie zuerst
liegen lassen sollen ja es ist ja so
chronisch unterbesetzt die Folge
überforderte Ämter und
zuständigkeitswirr war deswegen ist es
auch sagen wir mal bemerkenswert wie
nennt sie Feser auf die Morde von
Burgstädt reagiert hat wie konnte es
sein dass ein solcher Täter noch hier im
Land war wie konnte das passieren und
wie konnte es passieren dass er trotz so
vieler Vorstrafen nicht länger im in
einer Justizvollzugsanstalt war ja wie
konnte das passieren und wo ist
eigentlich diese Innenministerin die all
diese Fragen beantworten müsste
zum Beispiel warum das Bundesamt für
Migration den Schutzstatus von Ibrahima
immer noch nicht aufgehoben hat und
warum das BAMF erst durch die Morde
erfahren hat dass der Mann in Hamburg in
U-Haft saßmonate lang wegen eines
Messerangriffs gut klar dazu müssen wir
jetzt erstmal rauskriegen wem das BAMF
unterstellt ist ist wahrscheinlich ein
wahnsinnig komplexes Organigramm denn
ich meine Sonnenbank geht ja nicht
selbstständig das untersteht wir gucken
mal nach Moment
ach so nennt sie Feser ja dann Frau
Feser die übrigens im Januar letzten
Jahres im Bundestag die
konsequente Rückführung von Straftätern
angekündigt hat was seitdem konsequent
nicht passiert ist insgesamt stehen
50.000 abgelehnten Asylanträgen 13.000
Abschiebung im letzten Jahr gegenüber
und natürlich sind Leute wie Ibrahima
eine absolute Minderheit unter den
Asylbewerbern klar aber eben eine extrem
gefährliche Minderheit und warum werden
wir nicht mal die los während andere
schon direkt von der Datenbank zum
abschiebeflieger gebracht wurden warum
ja weil die zur Arbeit gehen
weil die zur Arbeit gehen und die
Polizei weiß wo die sind bei der Arbeit
genau im Gegensatz zu abgetauchten wie
Ibrahim a das kann man den Bürgern alles
absolut nicht mehr erklären liegt aber
natürlich auch an den Herkunftsländern
sie haben einen Land der sagt nö der ist
straffällig geworden wir stellen ihm
einfach keine Papiere aus auch das ist
möglich oder sie kriegen keine
Begründung unseren bestellen keine
Papiere aus ja die sagen dann nee den
Kriminellen
was also tun die Innenminister der
Europäischen Union haben gerade
vorgeschlagen solche Länder mit
schlechteren dieser Bedingungen unter
Druck zu setzen man nennt sich Weser
noch am selben Tag abgelehnt dabei hat
genau das bei den westbalkanstaaten sehr
gut funktioniert deren Bürgern gibt man
arbeitswieser für Deutschland im
Gegenzug nehmen Sie abgelehnter
Asylbewerber zurück
aber kommt wer weiß vielleicht gibt es
jetzt die Wende denn haben Sie
wahrscheinlich gar nicht mitgekriegt die
Ampel hat seit dieser Woche einen
sonderbevollmächtigten für
migrationsabkommen ja Joachim Stamm
ehemaliger FDP-Minister aus NRW ja für
den musste wohl
für den musste wohl dringend Arbeit
gefunden werden schon allein um in
Zukunft sowas hier zu verhindern wovor
hast du Schiss
[Musik]
ja
unverbindlicher Tipp als
migrationsbeauftragte sollte Herr Stamm
dringend Abstand nehmen von
Karnevalsliedern ich sage nur die
Karawane zieht weiter nur als Tipp
selbstverständlich muss gerade in
Deutschland auch in Zukunft Schutz
gewähren logisch aber umso wichtiger ist
es für die Akzeptanz der Asylpolitik in
der Bevölkerung mindestens Straftäter
und Gefährder wirklich konsequent
abzuschieben gleichzeitig muss es aber
auch mehr legale Wege in unseren
Arbeitsmarkt geben das sage nicht nur
ich als links grün versiffter gut Mensch
das sagt die deutsche Wirtschaft
Stichwort chronischer Fachkräfte Mangel
die größte Bedrohung für die deutsche
Wirtschaft natürlich ja
sie kriegen doch kein Handwerker mehr so
gesehen so gesehen geht das neue Chancen
aufenthaltsrechte Ampel schon in die
richtige Richtung damit du als
Metzgermeister nicht mehr selber nach
Indien fliegen muss um Azubis zu finden
so wie er hier ich habe parallel meine
Betrieb
definiert wer hat in der Bedarf nach
junge indische wir haben ja Angst
zurückrufen irgendwie was was soll das
indische bis jetzt ganz verrückt das ist
ja wahnsinnig ich bin schon wahnsinnig
kannst doch erinnern nehmen für die gute
wurstspätzle
natürlich kannst du das das kannst du
machen das klappt super und nicht nur
bei ihm und nein das ist keine
Multikulti Agenda sondern Ökonomie in
Deutschland fehlen 538
000 qualifizierte Fachkräfte so viele
Jobs kann nicht mal Nancy fazer
übernehmen
wie will man die alle mit Leuten
besetzen die schon hier wohnen das geht
doch gar nicht warte mal
538.000 das entspricht ungefähr der
Einwohnerzahl von Hannover das heißt wir
lösen einfach schweren Herzens Hannover
auf ne da kann man drauf verzichten und
dann zwingen wir sämtliche Hannoveraner
eine der freien Stellen zu übernehmen ja
auch die alten klaus Meine von den
Scorpions wird Grundschullehrer darf
alle Fächer unterrichten außer Musik
natürlich Carsten Maschmeyer schicken
mir in die Altenpflege zur Strafe weil
er mit seiner awd-druckerkolonne die
ganzen Rentner abgezockt hat und Gerd
Schröder wird Klempner den lassen wir
den ganzen Tag Scheiße repariert
[Musik]
weil wir es können das grundsätzliche
Problem bei uns in Deutschland ist es
hat man ja auch nach den Silvester
Krawallen von Berlin gesehen nach drei
Sekunden heißt es spätestens wir gegen
die ja meine klar waren das Idioten die
in Neukölln Rettungskräfte mit
Feuerwerkskörpern beschossen haben aber
es waren überwiegend unsere Idioten muss
man erstmal zur Kenntnis nehmen die
meisten waren Deutsche und keine Post
deutsche passt deutsche gibt's nämlich
gar nicht und viele der Betroffenen
Polizisten und Feuerwehrleute hatten
selber Migrationshintergründe nichts wir
gegen die Pauschalisierung bringen
einfach sowas eh nie weiter mit der
Logik könnte ich sonst auch sagen der
Mann an sich ist das Problem kann ich
aber nicht ne ja
klicke wenn ich da mal kurz einhaken
dürfte jetzt machen Sie sich selber ein
bisschen einfach dr Albrecht Humboldt
von der heute schon
Wissenschaftsredaktion was machen Sie
denn hier auf Fakten Hinweisen natürlich
gibt es da ein objektives Problem mit
dem männlichen Homo sapiens und es
bringt nichts da weg zu gucken Männer
begehen fünf Mal so viel Straftaten wie
Frauen speziell bei Tötungsdelikten
können die uns gar nicht mehr einholen
wir haben nur eine Strategie zur
Problemlösung Gewalt Männer haben 100%
aller Weltkriege verursacht Zufall ja
ein paar von uns verdienen Milliarden
das stimmt aber wir geben sie dann auch
direkt wieder aus mit Himmel Raketen ins
Weltall zu fliegen
hier mal ein paar rein zufällige
Beispiele für Männer
so wirklich jede valide Studie der Welt
spricht für den Mann als tragischen
chromosomenunfall
von unseren kognitiven Fähigkeiten mal
ganz zu schweigen Jungs sind die
komplette Schullaufbahn schlechter als
Mädchen und wieder spielt das
Testosteron dabei eine Rolle Mädchen
suchen nicht nur mehr Blickkontakt sie
können auch deutlich besser sprechen als
Jungs
sie sprechen früher und ihre Sprache
entwickelt sich schneller
Tatsache ein dreijähriges Mädchen sagt
regelmäßig Sätze wie schau mal Vater ein
Regenbogen der entsteht wenn sich das
Sonnenlicht an den Wassertropfen in der
Luft bricht ein gleichaltriger junge
sagt maximal da Auto
und zeigt dabei auf ein Fahrrad also
Entschuldigung
jetzt wird es aber wirklich sexistisch
ich wünschte
21,3% der zweieinhalbjährigen Mädchen
tragen keine Windel mehr aber nur 7,5%
der Jungs warum weil wir es gerne warm
haben in der Hose oder
hier anderes Beispiel laut einer Studie
von 2021 lassen sich Männer eher von
Attraktivität Blenden Frauen Vertrauen
attraktiven Männern deutlich weniger
kann ich auch nicht bestätigen mir
vertrauen total viele Frauen ja
ja ähm
anyway und on top haben Männer auch noch
eine sehr seltsame Vorstellung von dem
was sie für Frauen attraktiv machen ja
aber Herr Dr was wollen Sie denn mit all
dem eigentlich sagen fordern sie die
Abschiebung von Männern von allen
Männern oder was Quatsch gar nicht nötig
wenn wir so weitermachen sterben wir
sowieso aus ich sag mal noch zwei drei
Silvester und der Fall hat sich von ganz
alleine erledigt
Böller im Po Mexiko Albrecht meine Damen
und Herren vielen Dank
kaum wir müssen Strom sparen macht die
Kamera aus Jürgen heute machen wir Asma
bis denn ihr den Kanal für die nächsten
Schimpfwörter